واننا امام ما يمارسه المحتل الجبان منذ
100 يوم فاجانا العدو من جديد وكبد اناه
ولا زلنا نكبد خسائر فادحه واثمان باهضه
فاقت
وستفوز خلال 100 يوم بفضل الله
وعونه نحو الف اليه عسكريه
صهيونيه غلت في قطاع غزه في شماله ووسطه
وجنوبه كما نفذنا مئات المهام العسكريه
الناجحه في كل نقاط توغل وعدوان الاحتلال
اعلنا عنها اولا باول وقد ابدع مجاهدو ولا
يزالون رغم الفارق الهائل في ميزان القوى
المادي والعسكري ورغم ما يرتكبه العدو من
جرائم اباده ومجازر هي ع مسجله باسمه في
التاريخ الا ان مجاهدينا بعون الله
وتاييده حافظوا خلال 100 يوم على تماسك
صفوفهم وازدادوا قناعه بالدفاع عن ارضهم
امام عدو همجي بغيض فقدموا التضحيات
العظيمه وسطروا ملاحم عز نظيرها في هذا
الزمان وتمت سوا في عقدهم القتاليه
واستبسل في تكبيد العدو خسائر هائله في
صفوف ضباطه
وجنوده وان الملاحم التي سطرها
مجاهدو مما اعلنا عنه وما لم نتمكن من
اعلانه بعد ستخلد كواحده من اعظم وابدع
واعدل واقدس المعارك في تاريخ امتنا